hey look uh i saw the uh trailer for
this movie this
tv show you did uh called professionals
oh yeah
and uh and and i saw it i was like it
looked like the production value was
huge and i remember you going to do this
and i and i see it and it's one of those
things where i've been on stuff that all
of a sudden they hold it for six months
and then nothing happens with it
then i've done stuff and all of a sudden
they do eric like what's going on with
it
do you even know what's happening with
it because it looked cool [ __ ] yeah it
was crazy we went down to
south africa for three months and we
shot and it was a it was a very uh
adventurous shoot um but a very exotic
thing you know for me it was it was
supposed to be a uh
like an a team slash oceans 11 sort of
idea um
it was all daylight it rained for one
hour and three months in johannesburg
that is all blue skies like that's just
the season there
which is the exact opposite of what
vancouver is
if you think about it but um it was a
very adventurous crazy dangerous shoot
yeah you got shot at right well i didn't
but one of our cars did
uh another cast member got carjacked and
and i listen i don't want to go and
say that johannesburg is
i mean it's not a safe place but some of
the people we worked with who were from
johannesburg
it's just the norm for them but uh one
of the
one of the wardrobe people's uh
their car got shot with an ak-47 like
crosstalk all right
wait wait what day was this in the shoot
was this day three because day four i
would have been on a plane
no this was probably four weeks in but
every day i had
i had three security guards and they're
not just like security guards and suit
these guys are like military guys
we've got with machine guns and i had
three guys with me
at all times did you feel safe with them
i mean i felt safe with them
uh i would leave the hotel and i would
get into an armored vehicle
that had a trail vehicle that was
armored there were two guys with me and
one guy in the back one and the idea
they told me is
i go what if we get pulled over or what
if we get an
accident because i was like curious
about this this lifestyle and how they
handle it yeah
and they're like basically if we get an
accident
one of us would put you in the trail car
and they would take you to the hospital
we're not waiting for the ambulance like
it was like
because you don't know if you're getting
carjacked you know it was very
i mean it sounds like a movie on its own
it was scary and the idea was for
jessica and thompson to come
down there once i got settled and it
really was just like
uh it wasn't safe so i you know they
didn't come down but you're right the
behind the scenes would have been
a little even more exciting and brennan
fraser
who's you know the co-star he got
carjacked
uh while we were down there yeah they
just
and they just wanted a cell phone
nothing else was he nervous was he
um he was a little shaken up the next
day as we talked about it
i think what happened you know you go to
these places
and you you know you're excited and
you're filming and you know
oh you're always looking for the best of
everything and when something like that
happens it really
kind of wakes you up to like oh wait a
second
i'm this is it sounds ridiculous but
like this is real
so did you really feel like what
percentage of you every day on set was
thinking
i i could this i could be in trouble
here were you always was it always in
the back your head
um i felt i was safe on set i was safe
when i like once i left the hotel room
with those guys with
with you with the three armed security
you know
uh like ex-military guys um
i mean i was safe um
but on the weekends like the two days
that you'd have off you don't leave the
hotel
and if you do you have to call and the
three guys show up and they go with you
what were their names i don't i don't
remember their excitement
johann and they and they rotate out but
they're
they're also the same guys who go into
the safari
or into the um reserves and protect
rhinos
real men is the word they're real men
real
live or die situations for sure like you
and i like to joke around a lot there's
some things they didn't
want to joke around about i i'm like you
know what like i'd be driving home
like i don't know friday night at nine
o'clock whatever and
they're like do you have any plans for
the weekend because they want to know if
they need to be there to go with me and
i'm like
no i think i'm just gonna go for a jog
you know
at night at like 2 a.m see how far i can
go and they were like
don't joke about that like that's not
funny what
you